welcome back to new rockstars i'm philip
molina and this is fitness origins it's
a fitness competition show
inspired by the movies of the mcu i'm
about to call eric and tommy but real
quick i want to talk about how they did
last week because
they didn't get all their work outside
now i went really out of my way to make
these workouts as
crazy short as possible they don't
require any equipment
so uh when i hear you know it's still
finding the time to fit these in that's
really the challenge i don't know if i
can buy that excuse so this week
i came up with a different idea how's it
going
oh good fit is a fiddle i think i'm done
actually i don't think there's any more
need every week or diet every week uh
no we're just in week two actually uh
and you guys i
should know if you're following along
that this week is all about
iron man 2 the cream of the crop iron
man movies
yes hey no seriously i they're okay we
don't love
every element of iron man 2 whiplash is
a little bit of a
interesting character i want my board
a bird but my one of my favorite iron
man things period
is this version of the iron man suit the
mark v suit it's the portable suitcase
suit eventually he
like has it inside of his body but you
know we can't do that with you guys
i'm willing to put a suit inside my body
is that what my butthole hurts so bad
when i wake up
nope those are the mountain climbers
eric i told you
yeah okay so uh tony understands in this
movie that
the whole point of doing this is that
the bad guys can show up anytime
anywhere so he makes a super suit that
goes with them wherever he goes so
i was thinking about how last week you
know it felt like you guys were having
trouble finding time for the workouts
so what if maybe any time works for a
workout
uh what i'm going to do is call you just
at any time
and let you know it's time to do today's
workout okay but
make anything easier that just makes it
scarier we're like having a nuclear age
now
like north korea can attack us at any
point yeah exactly
i don't want to be you know too
forthright with my personal life but i
have a lot of people coming over for
overnights and if
they're disturbed by me doing air squats
and
jumping jacks and something like that
you know i don't want any of my lovers
to leave name
one lover you don't know her this guy
i set up the mystery of why my butt all
hurts so bad and bottom line
we're working out together no guys it's
not supposed to make it easier it's
supposed to call out that
really as long as you're kind of ready
to go honestly just wear shorts
i wear shorts all the time for that
reason um you should be good to do the
bodyweight workouts
anytime anywhere so basically have your
phone on you
and uh let's have some fun excited
yeah i guess i get some pretty bad
reception here though so if i missed the
call
it's just no reception yeah way up in
the hills the hollywood hills
so we're kind of back at the start of
these exercises
i feel more confident going through them
with that confidence comes
a drive to challenge myself to try to do
it for longer periods of time
i don't know if i was ready to do longer
periods of time but i did go longer than
10 seconds for each of the three things
plank day i feel like my core is getting
stronger
so day two is kind of a fun one it's
every other day that i hate i'm awake
now
because philip just called me to work
out i don't know why he did that
you like my mickey mouse pillow
a little bit of improvement on some of
the workouts still really hard still
doing mostly the modified stuff which i
guess could be discouraging but
you're starting from nothing you know
what would tony stark do probably
i have sex with a beautiful woman so you
know it's iron man 2 theme week so
no excuses right hello
sure tony stark had to be ready to turn
to iron man at a moment's notice
apologies for leaving in the middle of a
recording you know if it's just the
difference between you being active and
not at all doing anything you can
usually fit in five minutes of jumping
jacks five minutes of high knees
push your body to do something mountain
climbers
i hate mountain climbers so much who
invented those some sort of sick freak
i hate them but we did we got through it
a ranking of
worse it goes three then four then five
then one then two
two is just planking i can handle that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what is it
[Music]
no it's too early oh yeah i'm getting up
looking for you i had my camera
recording me while i sleep to make this
bit work
uh and i'll tell ya you know i'm
starting to get to the point where when
i wake up
i feel ready to go and less needful of
like
a caffeine hit starting to see some
positive benefits from it
how's week two good oh week two has been
great
and uh you know i like to say monday
through thursday i'm all about support
eric is my teammate in this process
come friday night it's game time and now
you are my enemy and i look into your
face and i just hate it i love it but i
hate it
see tommy that's where you and i differ
you have this anger towards me as we
head up into the challenge
and i have that anchor for you the whole
goddamn weak [ __ ]
i have your your name written on my
goddamn knuckles as i'm doing pull-ups
it's not even part of the [ __ ]
challenges but i'm coming after you bec
told
you better look out i'm cutting a promo
and this one's going on pay-per-view
you're not putting this one on basic
cable uh i watched your vlogs this week
um good work so far eric uh
you you've got all your workouts in
great job yeah i felt like i got a
better handle on it this week
because uh you know after losing the the
challenge last week
i realized i need that cheat meal and i
want that gmail and i'm getting that
goddamn cheat meal and
it wasn't too bad the uh the phone calls
at all random hours
uh didn't like that part i was on hour
three of the snyder cut and then i just
had to set up
in the studio in the bedroom here and
just gotta do the blanks where i was
so i could get back to watching the
snyder cut and hey the snyder cut was a
lot better because then i'm like hey i'm
giving myself the abs that aries has
uh tommy uh how'd you do with all that
you know uh your calls were shocking to
me they were surprising and upsetting
uh a lot of calls mid lovemaking which
was upsetting for my partners
and multiple partners usually you don't
know her she lives in canada i'm not
gonna say it again she goes to a
different school
i met her at camp all right i want you
guys to focus on the actual motivation
though for the challenge that sweet
sweet door dash
cheat meal do you guys uh know what you
want yet have not been able to eat
at least a weekly staple for me a good
solid breakfast burrito
gonna tell me we're not going just
brisket we're not going just ribs we're
not going just pulled pork we're going
all three
and maybe a little piece of cornbread
and maybe some macaroni salad
and maybe some collard greens and then
maybe a sweet tea
let's say uh barbecue ribs okay ribs is
great but
uh guys i do want you to keep in mind so
doordash is providing us
uh with your cheat meal uh and also with
the healthy meal to the
loser winner uh but just something you
guys should know is that you could be
using doordash all week long
for getting healthy food too i know that
you guys you know have all kinds of
reasons of why it might be hard to get
healthy food
you can get grocery store deliveries
from doordash i know that it can be
really hard when you're out there and
you like i know you're in the store and
then you're in the checkout aisle and
there's all that candy or whatever
just make a list of healthy items uh for
your
from your supermarket and ordered that
through doordash doordash
bring me peanut m ms uh all right guys
for a limited time our listeners can get
25
off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app
and enter code nerd fitness that's 25
off up to a 10 value and zero delivery
fees on your first order when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and that code again is nerdfitness
do not forget it
25 off your first order with doordash as
always subject to change in terms of
apply guys it's time to work out
let's get a number yeah yeah that's
every week
every week i'm gonna work you out
right after iron man 2 comes thor which
inspired today's challenge
as you guys know thor's weapon of choice
for most of the mcu
is mjolnir what's miami an enchanted
hammer given to him by his father but
that enchantment means that
only someone worthy can even move the
hammer so
do you guys feel worthy no great so
today's challenge is to lift mjolnir to
at least hip height
before your opponent so there's going to
be a speed element here but first
you have to become worthy right so we've
got these poor little townspeople down
here who are in desperate danger
you have to save their lives in order to
become worthy you save them
by taking them over to that hospital box
i made the more lives you save the more
worthy you are it's not hard
well it's maybe a little hard the lesson
here guys is that you got to put in the
work
before you can have the glory yeah
that's unfortunate
all right guys ready let's find out
who's worthy save those lives in three
two one go
all right nice job can you lift it
absolutely no all right because you're
unworthy
uh all right okay betty this is your
life you see
i got you dad why did i be dead
i did put your family members in there
are you worthy
it's like harder now
all right son it's your turn yeah i
saved my son because i care about the
future
are you worthy
nope i think a breakfast burrito almost
came out of my butthole
make sure we get that if that happens
any councilman peters i care about
democracy
why are we saving the dogs there are
dogs in there
oh eric there oh no
you must not want that breakfast burrito
huh i care more about the lives
they look the lives
tommy it could be this could be it
one more one more
[Music]
all right eric
wins the thor's worthiness challenge
absolutely
we're all worthy deep down
all right so it looks like eric won the
challenge but that does not mean he won
the week of course
we still got to do the math on who had a
better health and fitness week overall
and then we'll figure out who wins that
sweet sweet door dash cheat meal
all right i've got math to do guys bye
all right happy sunday boys ah how you
feeling feeling
great i'm nervous i really want that
barbecue you guys both had to save
people and see who was more uh
worthy of lifting mjolnir it was
definitely eric which was surprising
uh tommy behind the scenes we had a
little bit of money on who was going to
be able to
just like manhandle that turns out
the man that could handle it was eric
hey a lesson was learned we're all going
to grow from it and i am so [ __ ]
pissed right now i cannot believe it
hey you know we're missing the deeper
lesson here uh
of it's not strength it's worthiness
right and uh i'm just saying
before the challenge i did see tommy
over on the set whispering to each of
those people bricks saying i really
don't care about you
i want you to burn i want you to burn i
want you to die slow death
oh god okay guys this is always a
disaster let's just get to it uh this
poor doordash person i think has been
waiting
uh at your doors uh each person uh let
me tell them that they can
hit you up and we'll find out who won uh
their cheat meal eric wanted a breakfast
burrito and tommy wanted some barbecue
ribs
yeah you should both be knocking or
ringing your bells now
okay all right what do we have
uh eric tommy hold up what you got
delivered a breakfast burrito so big
it's hard to get out of the bag
huge breakfast burrito tommy would you
get i think whatever barbecue place you
ordered from only brought me the the
crudite
it did not bring the rest of the meal so
i think we need to call them
there's a gaping crater in it where the
cup of ranch should be and on my receipt
it says
no ranch so i'm not sure how magic you
did but you took the fun out of it i uh
i just now need to leave a better uh
review for that restaurant that was able
to take my note uh please do not include
the ranch dressing
but honestly you guys did a pretty good
job this week especially
uh staying flexible and working out all
kinds of hours i really feel like you've
earned
this well-deserved rest day and these
delicious meals that you both get to
enjoy
as for you guys that are watching at
home so make sure to comment what you
think the next challenges should be i'm
definitely gonna be looking for ideas
inspired by the upcoming mcu movies that
are hard to come up with
uh also reminder that epic hero labs is
giving away nine more playstation
5's just subscribe to the epic hero labs
youtube channel then go to
epicuroshop.com giveaway to submit your
information
and see how to get even more entries and
you guys
next week is a biggie it's avengers week
so make sure you don't miss it who was
us i think we have to be there we're
right yeah you guys have to be there
it's your job okay let's make it sure
okay all right
i'll see you guys then bye
[Music]
foreign
[Music]